okay um come on now rub my me help me
out this is you guys who mostly at the
end of last lesson hands up if you are
handing in your if you would like to
hand in your bookmark alive because I
mean it was quite a few of you yeah okay
all right thank you hands down all right
now I did I said this woke up a
politically richard cuz we should
actually have the sense to predict that
this is going to happen and he asked me
what date he can we talk about this yes
yes this happened before is happened
last week I Robbie we don't Elliott no
child here's the issue
okay many of you want to hand in your
bookmark way to me and you've given me a
variety of reasons okay
the main one being you've gotten an easy
coming up is it okay so you're two years
ago okay now here's that I don't know if
you ever thought about the difference in
reasons and excuses how would you define
the difference between a reason and
excuse and excuses are what have to be
true an asteroid fell on myself saying
again Robbie right okay so like a reason
you skew I think that's I didn't have an
answer in my head that's pretty good one
the dippers any reason excuses it it's
alleged something happened I'm assuming
it's true it's not a lot right but what
makes it an excuse is that it's not a
valid reason that you shouldn't have
done it like it's a it's what I'd like
to bring up as you know what justifies
me but it doesn't really justify so
example how long have we known about
this adjective like did it just come up
honestly
when was the wet feedback when was the
first time you heard about like you
actually had a sense of the time
yes again like about six months six
months way before this bookmark was and
you guys do as well like the bookmarks
as well we're not they haven't come out
of the blue like we've been doing it
every way this is the third one now
okay so here's here's what I'm trying to
put across to you okay
this agra Zia might have been the
occasion for a late submission but it's
not the real reason and you are lying to
yourself if you're saying I can't hand
this in at this time when it was you
because of this exact okay now if you
remember one thing okay put pre pens and
books down or like I mean we'll see me
after this all right away if you learned
one thing from this okay because the
point is not that you hand something
intimate I actually hate getting your
bookmarks because it means a wrap a
little work for me okay so that's not
the point it doesn't count for anything
like a we've talked about it's not
assessment okay but this is a lesson for
you guys right you guys aren't that
funny kind of point where you you're not
adults
yet but you're also not children either
like you have a responsibility and
everything okay
and the big difference I think between
children and adults is not ability okay
like if we talked about ability you guys
can do some things way better than a lot
of the adults you know myself included
okay so it's nice things and don't
adjust better it's tough though
on the whole they are okay I think the
difference is children make excuses
right adults take responsibility if
something happens an adult can't deliver
right it doesn't it doesn't matter it's
like Oh throwing some excuses or
something like that
well what kinds of things do Alice have
to do with like you know I don't have
money or I you know I can't I'm not
gonna be on time I'm not gonna arrive
somewhere at a certain time or those
kinds of things right the excuses mean
nothing like they don't help pay the
bills they don't you know get you to
your destination on time okay and not
says I screwed up I did something wrong
work out what it is now get on with it
right so I'm gonna suggest from both it
most of you probably the agony
not the problem a failure to plan a bit
organized was the real problem okay
because you knew the exam was coming and
you knew the bookmark was due on a
certain day right I mean this bookmark
free was a long one compared to maybe
bookmark two but people have still hand
it to me either early or on time okay
and if it was too much you have plenty
of opportunity come talk to me okay so
if you're gonna hand it in to me mate
I'll take note of that you know but
that's not the important thing
the important thing is that you've learn
and that you fix whatever is the problem
that's causing this okay because you're
not going to get bookmarks all the way
through next year because I would die if
I kept on Magni in that many bookmarks
okay but you're still gonna have to keep
up the same level of work right it's
just that you won't know that something
is wrong because you might have a
bookmark that I know I didn't have to I
couldn't hand it in on time you just
fall behind and then when the exam comes
would be like okay now I'm in trouble
right so take some responsive to take
responsibility for your own errors okay
we all make them so just learn from them
okay